be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay for those of you guys who are
watching this video and who are a fan of
the boys you are going to see that video
later on today that one is like three or
four issues this one's a one-shot so I'm
having my editor work on this one first
and then send the boys out later on
tonight so don't worry you know the
unser servers will be on patreon today
and the censored version of course will
be out on YouTube so I haven't forgotten
about you not leaving you hanging but
any event so absolute carnage the
immortal Hulk this is a really really
cool story that goes into why it is that
Venom merged with with the Incredible
Hulk right because remember when it
comes to venom merging with the Hulk and
really in more recent years it's usually
one of these things where you kind of
give permission right where's kind of
like I'm willing to bond with you and so
when venom successfully bonded to the
Hulk really kind of the background
question was like why did the Hulk let
it happen and what this does is it
basically explains that but it's
actually a viewing building on some
pretty big things here it really goes
into the notion of like the one below
all and all the symbiote got and this is
pretty significant and probably one of
the biggest comics or one of most
important comments it's gonna come out
right so that's why um for those you
guys who are new to comics when you come
across a story that you like it's always
important to at least skim the tie-ins
for different events that are going on
because a lot of times like tie-ins for
the events will be really really big
right I mean we saw it with like
original sin and Jonathan Hickman is a
vendor's and New Avengers you learn the
Captain America was originally part of
the Illuminati and you had to know that
if you were going to understand
everything that came after right so your
small little things like that small
little moments like that this also
actually kind of has a pretty big
explanation that comes in it as well but
what it does is it initially picked up
with Bruce Banner kind of in this dark
room now in reality this is Bruce Banner
inside of his own mind which is
something to kind of point out here but
it's cool the way this goes down because
occasionally we see this in Marvel
Comics you see that like Bruce Banner is
is having like some kind of internal
conflict or he's having some sort of
discussion with himself like with the
Incredible Hulk or something like that
and it's been depicted in different ways
I like the idea of him basically being
in like a big black box right because
it's just sort of the inside and the
darkness of banners mind but of course
he's basically speaking to somebody off
panel and simply saying hey look like
maybe we should talk about how I got
here and now initially I expected this
kind of be like a run over of everything
we've seen with regards to immortal
immortal Hulk so far but we don't get
that and it's one of the great things
about a Ewing writing like Al Ewing does
not usually retread water if you see
kind of a recap of something that
happened before it's because within that
recap is something that you didn't know
before and so it's a really really cool
little thing here because what it does
is it picks up with the events between
the immortal Hulk the issue that we last
covered in the issue before that right
so I
basically between his conclusion and
what we end up getting is of course
Bruce Banner waking up in this hotel
room out in California for those guys
who were following that story when he
comes to there's a couple different
things that we get here the first thing
he does is he talks to like the Venom
symbiote more or less as it is who it is
that he's addressing and he simply says
like when you bond to a host you know
everything the host knows right like
you're awake 100% of the time when the
host is sleeping you're awake when the
host is awake of course you're awake but
you don't really forget anything he says
with me as the Incredible Hulk
whenever the Incredible Hulk comes out
or any version of the Hulk I don't
remember anything i black out now that's
kind of a really really big explanation
to offer here because what it does is it
is a basically shows Banner does not
know what the Incredible Hulk does and
over the years and Marvel Comics that's
been kind of wax and wane and played
with by various writers right like some
writers will say The Incredible Hulk
always knows what what banners doing a
banner always knows what the Incredible
Hulk does and it can be a little bit
frustrating because what it does is it
kind of creates a situation where you're
kind of asking the question if banner
doesn't know what the Incredible Hulk
does then why is it like three years ago
in the story that was written by the
about the Incredible Hulk the banner
knew what the Hulk was doing when he was
going about and engaging in his own
actions and it kind of works that way
right like if you go and you look at
world breaker Hulk for example wreck
pack really seemed to pitch the idea in
such a way that the Incredible Hulk was
able to reach that higher level of power
because he and banner were kind of in
agreement with each other that the
Illuminati have to pay for the suffering
of everything that went on you can also
interpret it as banner was never part of
the equation he had no idea what was
happening but banner references the
events of World War Hulk and he
references like some of the things he
did right so it gets kind of crazy in
terms of how all this sort of fits
together but the big takeaway is that at
the moment right now in the immortal
Hulk stories whenever the Hulk comes out
banner blacks out and doesn't know what
the Incredible Hulk was doing and so
following that you know where he
basically sits down and watches the news
broadcast about the you know that mass
grave that was dug up at a military
graveyard what it does is it asked the
question is general Thunderbolt Ross a
person who's been dug up but his behind
his body been taken and says that was
initially the kind of question that was
there was asked here by banner and it
was if that's the case and thunderbolt
Ross's body isn't there anymore then
should I tell Betty Ross right like the
daughter funderbolt Ross the issue with
this is that Betty in her harpie form
really in her inner inner Red Hulk heart
before she's so far removed from the
person that she was before she can turn
back into Betty but she doesn't want to
but she doesn't want to be that human
part of herself she's so far removed
from that from the person that Banner
knew they doesn't know how how she's
gonna react and in fact wouldn't you
talk to Jackie McGee the reporter that
today are just kind of following
everything that's going on
and really sort of an ally of vanarin
and the Hulk at the moment she says the
same thing you don't know how she's
gonna react she could freak out and like
destroy you or she could want to know
there's no real way to know here and
you're really kind of taking a risk with
regards to everything sort of popping
off and so as a result of that when he
basically spills the beans and tells her
he's kind of like how long could it take
you to get there like do you want to
know she says well it would take me 10
hours if I flew alone with you I don't
know it would take too long and we would
be seen so he basically says fold me up
right essentially kill me fold me up and
then like let me go and when that
happens the Incredible Hulk will
manifest you know after some time if
they're over the incredible knowing
what's going on the Hulk will manifest
and when that happens of course my body
will be healed because of the healing
factor of the Hulk and everything will
be fine and so ultimately they end up
flying out to this this place in North
Jersey to find the body of Thunderbolt
Ross being there and it's kind of a
crazy thing because you end up finding
out that what the what the federal
government had done is as soon as this
mass grave more or less was dug up that
Thunderbolt Ross his body was taken and
so it's kind of one of these things
worse like is this body out there
preparing to be used by someone are they
going to resurrect him you know and
that's one of the things that banner
says is that for those of us who were
gamma mutates we never really stay dead
right like we always usually end up
coming back in some form or fashion and
with the Incredible Hulk it's easy and
it makes sense if somebody goes to shoot
or kill the physical form of Bruce
Banner the Incredible Hulk will manifest
in an instant basically he'll banner
from his wounds and then go on a rampage
but for other characters they really
always seem to kind of make some sort of
return even if they lose their power
stand up giving their powers back to
somewhere along the line now it really
is kind of how you and kind of
communicating with this how like writers
treat mutates treat like you know
mutates like they always come back some
writer always brings to back somewhere
along the line or something like that
but even within Marvel continuity they
always end up making their return and so
it was kind of a cool moment it's kind
of a cool little thing there because
following that it is the incredible
thing okay if this is the case then like
we have to somehow figure out what's
going on with venom like how venom ties
into this and all that kind of good
stuff right and so when that happens
like when that goes on when the Hulk is
watching the police investigate the site
they say the reason why it was dug up is
because there was basically a younger
guy by the name of Angelo Fortunato who
we've talked about in our videos on all
the Verge's versions of carnage and
venom and so on uh who ultimately had a
venom Symbian right so venom in or Lisa
you know carnage will or venom or
somebody hosting a symbian is involved
in this which breezy Incredible Hulk to
kind of confront and figure out what's
going on and so inside Bruce banners
mind for a second I want to talk about
this he's he's met by a couple
personalities the first one is a
personality of Joe fix-it and it's kind
of
see a version of Bruce Banner and his
Joe fix-it form right because you never
really see that you never really see
banner what he's Joe fix it into Joe fix
of personality all you ever really see
is great Hulk and it's cool to see like
the human form of great Hulk right like
how does that personality manifest this
is also kind of a big deal as well
because when you look at the versions of
Bruce Banner you look at the verses of
the Incredible Hulk all you really see
is that you've got like banner as as a
singular personality and then like all
the other personalities are incredible
hulks but inside the mind of banner is
basically a whole bunch of banner
personalities that can turn into their
own versions of the Incredible Hulk it's
cool it's a really really cool bit of a
revelation here you know it seemed kind
of like a version as yo fixer that looks
like banner it's kind of Awesome you
know it's a pretty cool little thing to
show now you've also got like The
Incredible Hulk who shows out kind of
you know offers his own little tidbit
here it's kind of like it hurt like hell
to get crumpled up like that you know
it's a small little thing but ultimately
you know this journey of banner or I
guess of hulking banner trying to figure
out what's going on with venom and how
he ties into all this leads them into
confronting spider-man now of course
this little segment of the story takes
place during absolute carnage when
spider-man leaves Eddie Brock to go find
the Avengers right for those guys who
were following that story and was banner
running into him and basically saying
hey look like we need to have a
conversation
tell me about venom tell me everything
that you know about venom basically like
like spider-man kind of recaps carnage
you know the events of absolute carnage
and says like essentially could his
Cassidy's back in all hell's breaking
loose and there's this guy Knoll the
symbiote guard he's some kind of a
cosmic Satan and this immediately
resonates with Banner and this is when
we started to get into the what seems to
be the relationship between know all the
symbiote God and end like the one below
all because to refer to null as a kind
of cosmic Satan for spider-man to do
that drives banner to basically say like
it makes me think of the one below all
know the semi of God has some kind of
affection simile or is like is basically
the one below off but in a different
form and here's the thing that's
entirely possible
take for example the character of the
fulcrum in Neil Gaiman's Neil Gaiman's
Sandman comics I'm sorry not saying man
uh solo not Celestials Eternals comic
there we go the fulcrum is this being
that kind of resides at a bar this sort
of like where were Celestials go when
they basically die like when they pass
on and the fulcrum is this this
astronomically powerful being but you
don't know anything about him the only
real sort of indication you have is in
those eternal stories itself where it's
like he might be like an aspect of the
one above all and even then it's just
sort of guesswork right there's nothing
that definitively says here is what the
fulcrum is and
here like the Volcom doesn't say like oh
I'm just an aspect to the one above all
is basically all I am like I'm just kind
of here to hang out you never get that
it's just kind of left to believe that's
the case but like that happens right at
least cosmic beings eat these super
powerful entities Creek kind of like
facts similes of themselves or work
through individuals and that's how
banner sort of perceives this in his
mind know the City of God and this is
entirely possible
Nova symbiote God is either a being
being worked through while by the one
below off or it is an aspect of the one
below off no maybe an aspect of the one
below all but it's autonomous he can go
out and do his own thing he has own
motivations but he he possesses a
fraction of the power of the one below
wall or the Rambla walls working
directly through him it's saying like
like controlling him that kind of a
thing but because of the relation
between the two the question is asked
like how does all this tie together and
that's why Bruce Banner ended up
allowing himself to be bonded with the
Venom symbiote at the end of the most
recent absolute karna storyline because
banner wants to know are the one below
all and all the same thing are they two
different beings is a coincidence is it
really just Peter Parker ran off a name
and banners reading too much into it we
don't know but algae doing is really
kind of teasing the idea that like
they're somehow in cahoots or related to
one another or they're somehow the same
being as it was a really cool thing
because what it does if that's the case
then it could be a scenario where we're
literally thrown below all has all
different kinds of fact similes that are
out there all different kinds of version
of themself that exist all throughout
the entirety of the multiverse right
because if the one above all is the
supreme creator the top being of the
multiverse then the one below all would
be like at the very bottom of it all but
like he's a multiversal entity as well
it's cool and it's a really interesting
idea because it kind of goes forward
like asking the question how close are
they how involved are they I'm excited
to find out like I really want to know
it's a cool thing to tease and I'm
really excited to see the answer for it
well that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob 4 if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]